have you ever had like a neighbor from
hell or like a bad neighbor
like japan aside no england i've been
pretty good
yeah i think you did you mentioned it on
trash taste they don't have sex yeah
oh no no no that was that was actually
oh
they could have sex in the next room and
i could record podcasts whenever i want
and be a youtuber it was great they
didn't complain at all and
i didn't complain about it from hell
yeah i did actually it was i never do
things
yeah it was it was actually like the
place i had moved to after that so it
was actually like the first place i'd
moved into with with sydney
and we just had this guy living above us
and we didn't know this one
when we moved in but uh we moved into
this house
that was basically like a hmo so house
of like multiple occupancy
which is like basically a house that has
been like it's cut off
it's been cut up several people living
in it so the walls
we didn't realize how thin the walls
were right
and we had a guy living above us that he
was
he was old he was an older gentleman and
uh definitely had
a few screws loosed right because he
uh he said that he would used to work
for the police
right and he would he would he would
bring this up constantly right because
in this in this house that we were in
they had like heavy fire doors right
so so we'd have to like really be
super careful when we were like closing
the doors like there's there's like
letting the doors go
but there's also like because these
doors were so heavy sometimes you just
have to like yank it in
and sometimes that yank was just a
little bit too much power
behind it and it would just like make
make a make a loudish noise right right
and so this guy living above us he was
he you know at the beginning he tried to
be a nice neighbor and we tried to be
nice neighbors as well
um and then it's we soon came to realize
that
this guy had like massive anger issues
right he he i'm pretty sure like one one
day he could be the nicest guy ever
and the next day he would just like blow
up for like the smallest reasons and
we're just like
yeah we kind of don't feel safe so like
every time every time we'd like uh every
time we'd like maybe
shut the door a bit too loudly he'd at
first he'd like tell us
right be like you please shut the door a
bit and a bit quieter and we're like
sorry
like that that was our bad we knew about
it and so we'd be
extra extra careful but you know when
you go out in and out your house pretty
often right and sometimes
you sometimes you just yank it a bit a
bit more harder than you
would uh sorry sometimes you yank it a
bit harder than you intended to
so one time he told us to uh to be
to be careful it's fine nothing happened
for a month
and then at around 7pm i just yanked it
and i was like oh [ __ ] that was a bit
loud literally comes downstairs [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] did i tell you jesus
christ like he literally
full on [ __ ] screams i'm like yo what
the [ __ ] is going on and like
from that moment on keep in mind this
was a month after the last time i had
accidentally shot it a bit a bit too
loudly i was like
yo sydney i'm thinking we're living
below a crazy guy here 7pm who gives a
[ __ ] yeah and it was 7pm as well it
wasn't even in the dead of night
what the [ __ ] did i tell you a month ago
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
and like so i uh so like i you know i i
don't do the japanese thing
i go up to him and i'm not knocking his
door i'm like yeah yeah bro let's let's
let's talk it out come on come on let's
let's let's come to an understanding
here
and so you know i i you know we we talk
it out and he's very polite and very
calm
um that's how he hit you man
he's very he's very calm about it right
um and
uh and we're just like look look mate
i'm i'm this is the first place we've
moved to with my new
girlfriend um and he was saying you know
just sometimes walls are very thin so
just keep in mind that i'm right below
you i'm like no i'm totally i totally
get it
after like 10 p.m that's when i'm like
that's when we're super quiet we'd
normally go to sleep because i go to
work the next day as well
um but you know sometimes we're not even
talking at a loud
kind of volume or whatever so you know
as long as you can understand
that we can we are a couple and we talk
as people do when someone else is in the
house then you know we'll try to keep it
down at late hours
cool and so we i go back downstairs
uh literally a week later not even
closing the door this time
i'm literally just having a normal
volume conversation with sydney
um and instead of shouting he starts
walking around
like really loudly like starts smashing
down on the floor
like this right like what what the [ __ ]
is going on like well i mean sitting
like what the [ __ ] is going on so like i
go back upstairs and i'm like is is
everything okay did
are you like are you having like a
stroke a heart attack what's going on
yeah and he's like
look you're being [ __ ] loud and i
just wanted to teach you a lesson
right this is what you get for speaking
loudly i'm just like
what the [ __ ] is going on so like this
is literally
scarred me for life right because like i
i was living
in fear that this guy was going to do
something yeah
because like over time because we lived
here for a year and a half and
obviously our relationship deteriorated
as it would when i felt like in [ __ ]
danger living in my own house and
sydney felt in danger living in in in
her in our house as well
and so it got to the point where some
days we'd just be talking and then he
just randomly slight like
start banging like start banging on like
his fridge doors or like his cupboard
doors like making a lot of noise when he
thought that we were making a lot of
noise and
we were just like talking and having a
normal conversation most of the time
and and event like eventually he went
from the
relationship went from me trying to talk
it out with him to being like dude what
the [ __ ] is your issue and he's like
bro i used to work in the police don't
[ __ ] with me man if
if i wanted i'd call them over i'd get
all my mates i'd get the boys over
and i'd get you out you you like all
just say the word
just don't [ __ ] with me and i'm just
like [ __ ] let's sydney we got to move
out as soon as possible like this was
like one of the big reasons
why we moved out and so on the last
night
where we moved out uh sydney was already
gone because she had gone back home
to america so it was just me and a mate
talking and
so it was me in a mate talking and we
were watching a movie um so we weren't
even talking it was just this
it was just the volume of the tv at that
point right
and we get this bang on the [ __ ] door
right
and this guy starts like screaming full
volume
in my face right he's just like i know
you're about to [ __ ] leave
and i'm [ __ ] i'm glad you're about to
[ __ ] leave but like i need to give
you one last piece of my mind
like [ __ ] you you've been the worst
[ __ ] neighbor of my entire life and
then and
then he starts going off about how he's
part of the police again i'm like
bro calm the [ __ ] down i'm like at this
point this is probably the most pissed
off i've been on i've been in my life
and i'm like
dude monk mode went out the window no no
no i'm just like dude
back the [ __ ] off yeah and then and he's
like and then
he he looks at me right looks like he's
straight in the eye and he's like go on
have a swipe go on go on because like
i know i knew he wanted me to throw a
punch
so he had a reason to call the police of
course and i'm just and i straight up
tell him i straight up look him in the
eye and tell him
dude you don't know who you're dealing
with here
i was a [ __ ] monk i'm not gonna punch
i'm like i'm [ __ ] zen right now dude
you can try as hard as you like i'm not
going to punch you and he gets closer
and he's like come on
it's easy go on i'm like dude just back
the [ __ ] off now please
i'm gonna re-enter my home please just
[ __ ] off
so sad and uh that was yeah jesus
that was the last i heard of him and
that was my neighbor from hell i really
hope
that no one ever goes through that
because how did you
how did you stay in there for a year and
a half dude um because i was a contract
oh yeah right literally like it was it
was hell because
any time that we wanted and like we
hated
being in that house eventually like
after about after about
six months to a year we just we stayed
at my parents house as
much as we could and then eventually we
just straight up just moved back to our
parents house
because it was it was like a [ __ ]
hell living in our house
um and that's like that's kind of why i
never like one of
that's why i hate apartment sharing now
because that that one experience has
taught me just i just i just want my own
space
i want no one's uh like a noise
complaint actually triggers me now so
i'm just like oh dude i don't [ __ ]
blame you after that jesus christ
and uh yeah i i had completely forgotten
about that until we started talking
about neighbors
well there you go wow digging up old
traumas looks like
only on trash days wow that's i've won
[Music]
nasa
jesus christ i'm sure he's happy i'm
sure i'm sure i'm sure he's happy now
i'm sure he's happy now
like i think i think the early signs
were there because um i'm sure that he
won't get a neighbor who's
like better than you anyway i'm sure
he's pretty yeah right yeah
because because like i think like there
were early signs that were there because
he was telling me about the dude that
lived
in that place before was also a young
person as well
and he would not stop complaining about
how much noise he made
and how how loudly he shut the door
i'm just like i mean i've shot the door
it's it's loud but it's not like [ __ ]
shake the house loud you know i probably
just get to the point where i just start
making noise to piss him off
and you can smoke a smack on my door all
day man i've got the sony uh
wx thingies i'm noise canceling noise
canceling headphones were made sure
we're gonna do break into my house [ __ ]
was this apartment made out of paper
like
i think so man i don't know i don't know
because in uk what is it like
10 p.m is the official time where you
got less make noise yeah so right before
10 pm i probably just blast music
non-stop and then tempe admits turn it
off and then rinse and repeat yeah
what's what's the worst they can do
because i was just trying to be a nice
lady before a number like a certain time
and
i think the noise pollution is below a
certain decibel i think they can't do
anything
right actually i don't think they can
donate like legally they kind of don't
think so i could be wrong on that i
don't think they can
as long as it's like within a reasonable
amount yeah so it's just it's just the
[ __ ] tax that you pay them
yeah yeah okay okay but you can just
start ignoring him right
maybe he'll take a swing maybe maybe you
know what i should have done just gotten
some
nice noise-cancelling headphones yeah
you should have i mean like just like if
he knocks on the door who cares bro
sleep through it what's he gonna do
break down your door
people who brag about that kind of stuff
normally don't have the strong ties they
make it out to be you know
no i don't know i i mean i feel like he
was an ex-cop for a reason right
he's not a current cop yeah yeah